I heard a guy uh Dan Bulger out of
Boston is a great joke he's like
everybody gives America [__] for
building a wall but China built a great
wall and I've never seen any Mexicans
there
pretty good pretty good pretty good Dan
Bulger I I like that when you were
traveling around with Seinfeld did you
were you saying stuff like this or is it
you kind of have to keep it real clean
well we just did we did about four gigs
and we talked comedy the whole time
we're both huge comedy nerds and I'm a
huge fan of his but he's a he's a
regular dude like he just likes cars
baseball and stand up and we could we
could shoot the [__] for hours and he
likes an off-color joke I have a joke
where I say you know he's Jewish and I
say uh I met my my wife on that Jewish
app PayPal
we were you know he's a big Jew and we
were working on that joke and I was like
I wonder if I should say venmo or PayPal
and he goes you got to say PayPal
because it's got the word pay in it
that's more offensive and I was like
you're right yeah and it kills but that
was that was all him so he gets it he
loves Pryor and Bernie Mac and Carlin
and all that so he's he just chooses to
be clean for the challenge yeah Carlin
oh what a treasure big fan big fan a
huge hero of mine and I met him
wow yeah do you ever meet him I never
met him yeah I went to a book signing
and he he zinged me pretty good do you
like shopping on Amazon I do and good
news is Stevo's butt wipes for your
butthole are available on Amazon and if
you want a real bundle of a deal you can
get Stevo's hot sauce for your butthole
plus Stephen's butthole destroyer and
Stevo's butt wipes for your butthole
it's the butthole bundle available on
Amazon right now
yeah dude